king of all black sakes well listen the
chicken sandwich from Popeyes is one of
the best cities which is I've ever had
China you eat popeyes chicken hit him
with the high here's the guy who's the
expert
I like Popeyes a lot actually but I have
not had the chicken sandwich because you
can't get it it I mean David I can't
take it it's chicken they've done an
amazing job creating this demand for
this chicken sandwich a lot of Popeyes
you go to they don't have it they say
they're out of it if I had a product
that hunt I make sure I had the chicken
it creates more demand but yeah you're
right they should have it now the people
I know who I trust say it's really good
how could you know you're an expert I
can't believe I've wanted to try it I
have not been able to get it by the way
is pop-eyed the real pop I know how are
they able to use the name Popeye if it's
not owned by Popeye I think one of the
founders had the nickname and they first
came out with in Louisiana and they just
using who owns Popeye Warner Brothers
that's a good question I don't know who
owns actual Popeye the cartoon John hi
no audio book is on the phone wants to
talk about Popeyes yes Jon hi no do book
good morning Popeyes love that chicken
yes a night yes center to alkyls aren't
open chicken on the run in a New Orleans
suburb of Araby where he served
traditional Southern Fried Chicken right
a few months passed and nothing much
happened so he decided to sell spicy New
Orleans style chicken and called the
place Popeyes Wow you've got a lot of
information absolutely
the name wasn't based on the spinach
eating cartoon sale or rather on gene
Hackman's memorable detective Popeye
Doyle from the classic film the French
Connection Wow you see that's what I was
just asking you in fact the John Hein in
the studio didn't even know that poor to
afford an apostrophe for Popeyes and
luckily had no trademark issues to deal
with John how is it the guy on the phone
who's your audio book yeah that was more
than you do clearly he does yeah I
forgotten the Popeye Doyle thing
actually but that is how they got over
on the trademark issue absolutely thank
you John I know do bug but he could go
on oh he's still going up on them what a
great book I'm so informed now Wow
really knows a lot
you